- [Interviewer] All right, Marty.
Nice to see you again.
How things been for you?
It's been a month or two,
since I've seen you last.
- I've been doing a lot of ...
struggling out there.
- [Interviewer] What's
been the hardest part
of your life lately?
- Getting money for something to eat.
Lost a lot of weight.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you haven't,
you haven't showered in a while too,
it looks like.
- Yeah, haven't showered..
haven't cleaned up in a while.
That, that, that, that hurts too.
It takes its toll.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
It just makes it hard for you
to feel good about anything.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] Hungry and dirty.
Do you view the world as a cruel place or
how do you see people?
You see people as generally good, or...
- I see people generally as good,
but at times I can see the total, the
the total other way around.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
there's some of both.
It's always a balance, right?
Have you spoken to your son
at all or anything like that?
- It's been a while since
I spoke to my son.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What is your daily routine typically?
You wake up...
Where are you living now?
You're just..
You have a blanket and you just
curl up on the sidewalk somewhere?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you, so
when you wake up in the morning,
what do you do typically?
- I try to figure out what..
(Marty stuttering)
where do I have to go
to get some money today.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So you're...
Are you panhandling?
Are you?
- Yeah. Pan-handling sometimes too.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
How much money will you get in a day of..?
- I made, I made about
$30 one time panhandling
over
by the park
the bar station.
Where the ....
cable cars come down.
- [Interviewer] What was the
best time of your life, man?
- When my son was born.
- [Interviewer] Your life was happy then?
- Yes.
It was.
- [Interviewer] How did things
begin to change for you?
What happened that you ended
up now living on the street?
You're using crystal meth, right?
- Yeah.
I love getting high.
The crystal meth really
relieves all the de de
de de de de de de pression that I get.
- [Interviewer] You're depressed, huh?
- Yes, I do.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think about your past
is the most problematic for you?
Something in your childhood?
- Yeah. My childhood.
You won't believe the
childhood that I had.
You won't believe it, if I told you.
No one's ever been treated as bad as me.
- [Interviewer] What was the worst part?
- Just being ne, ne, ne,
ne, ne, ne, neglected.
Not feeling wanted at all.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever do..
do you feel like you were
ever loved in your life?
- Well there's a song that says
the greatest love of all
is just.....it's to love,
love yourself.
So I've tried to love myself
(Marty stuttering)
since I've been out here
waiting to get picked up.
That isn't...
picked up the city.
- [Interviewer] Is this the worst point
in your life right now?
Do you think what you're going through?
- No.
- [Interviewer] But what do you think
would help you the most?
Housing, therapy?
Rehab?
- Getting picked up by my family.
- [Interviewer] Do they
know you're out here?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Marty,
would you like to wash up
and take a shower?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever
feel like life is just unfair?
- I do.
- [Interviewer] With
the trials that you had
it would be easy to think that, right?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What was the
roughest thing you went through
in your childhood?
You said neglect, but I mean
what kind of stuff would
your parents do to you?
- My mom would
wait for me every day when
I come home from school
like this.
She would make me flinch
As I walked by..
She either make me...
she either punched me or
hit me in back of my head
or she wouldn't do nothing...
She wouldn't do anything to me at all.
That was the worse thing
coming home from school.
- [Interviewer] Do you still
have hope for a better life?
How old are you now?
- I'm 53.
- [Interviewer] 53.
Do you still have hope for
getting your life together
and having a better life?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What would
you say to your family
if you saw them after all these years?
- I don't know.
It's a good question.
- [Interviewer] Marty,
do you feel like you were
treated unfairly in life?
- All I know is I rolled a pair of sixes,
but it didn't pass go.
I deserve to get picked up.
- [Interviewer] All right Marty.
Well, thank you for coming in again.
Thank you for talking with me.
I'm gonna help you out today.
Thank you.
- Thank you.